you ever been to the candy shop
this is a daytime show
it's my answer
[Laughter]
I believe I said that although what do
you what are your comedic influences is
the show of rest of development have you
ever been arrested I've never been
arrested you said that you want people
to know that you're following that
you're only human yes you believe in
aliens I feel like I'm I've been
abducted by aliens right now yeah
they're just Bright Lights I'm talking
to 50 Cent I'm not sure this is reality
this is very good which one of us do you
think is better hosting the show I think
that we're separate but equal
explain you said you were discipline the
school facts and too many questions yes
how would you discipline me
no you guys feel this no no no no it's
actually a regular one so regular
question I'm just asking now you would
you know don't get carried away now